because we're asking people to story
tell 24 hours a day it's hard news alert
if you're still confused marketing got
[ __ ] hard right and so we have a lot
of people who'd rather shoot a
television commercial because here's
what you do
if you're spending a lot of money on TV
right you spend lots of time on it save
tons of time to not mess it up right
number two you get to go on the shoot a
lot of times so you what sounds more
interesting pops around with something
for six months and then go to New
Zealand for two weeks and be on the
shoot and really not have to do anything
and then God forbid if you get lucky you
get to go to the south of France and
catch a reward or what I pitched them
which is you can't sleep ever again the
customer matters and you need to put out
content every day and if you put up the
wrong piece of confident can be bad I
mean it's like not even close right so
that decision is there but if somebody's
a young progressive marketer and they're
thinking about their future and the
legacy and they know this is right they
realize wait a minute let me ride this
wave because this is going to help me
long-term